in this video i want to look at popular
uprisings in late medieval europe so
we're talking about between roughly the
14th and the 16th centuries and these
are sometimes known as peasants revolts
and we'll talk a little later about
whether or not that's a really
appropriate term given who actually
participated in the events
but for now
we'll refer to them as popular uprisings
which means that they involved a lot of
common people
as we look at these events we want to
keep two questions in mind sort of big
picture questions
the first is why did people choose to
revolt against their government and
especially after about the 1320s we see
a huge number of these popular uprisings
in in a way that just didn't happen
prior to this point so why did this
happen why did people rebel and secondly
we want to think about were these
uprisings successful
and if so what does success look like in
these circumstances
so i want to start with a specific
example and and that example is the
peasants revolt in england and this
occurs in the year 1381
so we have a picture here
and this is a picture from the
chronicles of jean freissa and he is
writing his chronicles of what's going
on at the same time that these events
are occurring so it's a contemporary
account the picture is actually from
later it's added back into the
chronicles later so the picture is not
entirely accurate of the period but it
does give us a sense of what it might
look like for the king to be confronted
by thousands of of angry subjects
but to go into what they were doing
there i want to start with a quote and
this again comes from the chronicles of
jean-frasa that i mentioned and this is
a quote that he attributes to john ball
and john ball is an english priest who
is preaching at this time and is
considered maybe one of the instigators
one of the people who helps start this
this revolt in 1381 and and part of that
is he's spreading ideas that challenge
the existing authority structure and he
goes on and says
i ye good people the matters goeth not
will to pass in england and that's kind
of an old time way of saying things
aren't going well in english
and then he goes on and says nor shall
not do till everything be common and
that there be no villains nor gentlemen
but that we may all be united together
and that the lords be no greater masters
than we be
so what he's saying there is we have
this structure of society in england
where there are the gentlemen the people
who are part of the nobility and they
have this access to political power and
economic power and then we have all
these other people who have to basically
do work to support this nobility
and he says we should really all be
equal and
things aren't going to be well in
england until we are
so that's a pretty radical message
especially for a medieval european
country
and he goes on and asks this question
and says what have we what have we the
common people deserved or why should we
be kept thus in service
servitude or bondage we be all come from
one father and one mother adam and eve
whereby can they say or show that they
be greater lords than we be and what
he's doing there is making an appeal to
the old testament of the bible and
saying that everybody is descended from
from the same pair of people
so we all really are equal in that sense
so why is it that the nobility have
access to this greater power and wealth
and i should point out that this idea of
challenging the social hierarchy is not
the only thing that's motivating rebels
in the in the peasants revolt in england
here there are a lot of other factors
and we'll talk about those a little
later so when we talk about medieval
european society before this point we
have a structure that has three estates
three levels or classes you could think
of this as and we have the clergy which
uh priests or friars and basically
anyone involved with the church and that
is the group of those who pray and you
have the nobility and this is going to
be your knights your your
people who are in control of large
tracks of land that they hold at the in
service to the king and to the the
kingdom
and those are the people who fight and
then at the bottom you have the people
who work
which is including most of the
population remember this is a low
technology agricultural society we're
talking about probably 90 plus of the
population is involved in agricultural
production in some way so this is the
largest chunk of society and they refer
to that as the peasantry so to to recap
that your your model is you have those
who pray those who fight and those who
work the society needs all of these
roles to function properly so all of
them are important so we want to think
about how do we go from this situation
where we have this relatively stable
social order where the different estates
are seen as more or less equally
important members of society to what we
see in england in 1381 where the people
rise up and challenge the authority of
the king
so there are three broad areas of
analysis that we can use to better
understand why we see these these
popular revolts breaking out throughout
the 14th century and the first one of
those is demographics or the study of
population
and we have two major events that
significantly impact europe's population
here the first one is the great famine
which occurs between 1315 and 1317 and
that refers to a sequence of poor
agricultural harvests due to
poor weather for agriculture at this
time the other event that has a major
impact on europe's population is the
outbreak of the plague uh the black
death it's called which occurs between
1347 and 1349 here
and this ends up killing between a third
and a half of europe's population so
what you see is a
big increase in
how much it costs to hire workers and
you actually see in england for example
in 1349 and 1351 you see a couple of
laws passed that try to keep workers
wages at pre-plague levels
so it's a response to the fact that
there are now fewer workers and that
makes workers more expensive
on top of that you also have the hundred
years war going on between england and
france it starts in 1337 and drags on
actually for more than 100 years but
that's the name they've given it
but that's expensive that that's costs
both governments a lot of money to to
keep fighting and maintaining militaries
and so at the same time that you have
these economic problems and struggles
you also have governments raising taxes
on people to try and pay for this
conflict
and the last thing that helps explain
some of these uprisings these popular
uprisings we saw a little bit already in
john ball's quote but we have religious
and cultural issues going on as well the
mendicant orders the franciscans and the
dominicans who are friars who go around
and preach uh to common people and and
preach the value of of poverty and
simple living
so when you have nobility who are living
very lavish and and extravagant
lifestyles you have some some pushback
against that as being perhaps against
the the popular religious attitudes of
the time um i mentioned at the beginning
that we would talk a little bit about
whether or not a peasant revolt was the
proper name for these events and and we
have in 1358 an event known as the
jacquari which is a popular uprising in
the north of france spurred because of
uh issues relating to the hundred years
war actually and the jacari gets its
name
from the fact that uh common people kind
of generically called
jacques bonhomme like a regular guy was
a jacques bonham and and that just
translates to something roughly like
jack goodfellow
so what you see is the elites the clergy
the nobility are applying this notion of
of being a peasant of being a commoner
in kind of a derogatory or insulting way
to anyone who's not part of the nobility
or the clergy and remember that when we
said what a peasant really is it refers
to a rural agricultural worker
and these revolts these uprisings
included a lot more than just rural
agricultural workers what they're trying
to do is to dismiss the uprising as just
bad behavior from from people who don't
know their place in society but in
reality it's much more complex than that
and
so hopefully this starts to give us a
sense of why did people revolt against
the government at this time we had these
demographic changes that lead to these
economic changes and that leads in some
ways to changes in how people view their
roles in society to think about whether
or not these were successful we want to
think about more than just military
success because the fact is most of
these popular uprisings
lost militarily speaking the the
government had
more than enough manpower and money to
put down these popular uprisings so when
we think about whether or not these
popular uprisings were successful we
want to think about did they lead to any
major changes in in the social or
political structures even if they didn't
win military victories and in most cases
we do see some of those changes start to
take shape